I was sitting in an anthropology seminar
cramming for a final only half listening
to a fellow classmate described a
research project female genital
mutilation is the partial or total
cutting of the external female genitalia
for non-medical reasons she mechanically
described the processes usually carried
out by an older female relative and once
the ritual takes place it has almost
never discussed as she spoke
goosebumps began to form and I sat
paralyzed in my seat memories I ate
suppressants child that came flooding to
the foreground I was seven years old my
parents have sent my brother and me to
visit family in India for two months my
dad's sister decided to throw a party
for my brother at the party she pulled
me aside wielding a jumbo size Tobler
roan she said that if I stand on my best
behavior I wouldn't have to share it
with anyone even my brother my aunt was
a doctor so when she led me downstairs
for a clinic and instructed me to lie
flat on my back on her operating table I
didn't think to question her authority
with no anesthetic and very little
warning she performed a ritualized cut
after it was over we headed back to the
party in silence I remember sitting in a
corner by myself
unable to open the chocolate bar and
feeling sick to my stomach I blocked out
the memory until the day when I
discovered that would happen to me had
an acronym that could be found in the
glossary of a medical anthropology
textbook when I confronted my parents
they were stunned my aunt had carried
out the ritual without their consent my
father felt a unique betrayal this was
the same little sister he encouraged in
pursue medicine in the first place as I
learned more about the practice I
discovered that more often than not men
are oblivious and may not even know
what's happening to their community at
GMC dates back thousands of years
it is not rooted in religion or is it
bound by geography or class it is about
power and controlling female sexuality
and more survivors need to speak up